the One Piece manga just kicked off the
first major battle of the final Saga
with Luffy fighting a marine Admiral for
the very first time in over 500 chapters
on top of that our all-time favorite
secret agent has betrayed the straw ads
so once again and is trying to kill the
genius scientist Dr vegapunk but he is
now facing Zorro here who has the chance
to want it for all proof to us just how
powerful he actually is and of course
all of this is leading to the massive
conclusion of this entire Arc which
we're told will be completely shocking
the entire world and I do have some good
ideas what this event could actually be
but we of course have to kick things off
with the epic Clash promise between
Luffy and the Marine Admiral kizaru
because even though we barely got a
glimpse of it in this chapter the start
of this fight confirms that Luffy will
be taking on the strongest opponents
that the world government has sent to
the islands and this is of course a huge
moment for Luffy to show us just how far
he actually has become since the last
time that he faced a marine Admiral
because in case you've forgotten let's
take a look at exactly uh how much Luffy
has actually been crushed by the
Admirals in the past first he met
Admiral aokiji and was completely frozen
solid to the point of nearly dying then
the next Clash came during the chaos of
the Saba ODI Arc where Admiral kizaru
was sent to take out the straw hats
after Luffy punched a Celestial Dragon
and although he never directly clashed
with Luffy the Lightman was super close
to taking out the entire Straw Hat crew
but then when we reached the legendary
war at Marine Ford where Kizer who took
an active role to stop Luffy from
freeing Ace in fact he shot Luffy with a
laser beam sent him flying with a light
speed kick twice and then sniped the key
to Ace's handcuffs right out of Luffy's
hands but of course that's not even the
worst that an admiral has ever done to
Luffy because at the end of the war
Admiral Akainu killed his brother Ace
which just absolutely broke Luffy so
yeah Luffy has a huge score to settle
with these Marine Admirals which makes
this fight of course even more
interesting than it already is because
on top of the actual battle to save the
vegapunks and escape from the island to
elbaf there are now both personal and
World altering Stakes at play here so
let's actually go through all of the
scenarios of what could happen based on
the outcome of this fight and first off
no matter what I really don't think that
this will be an easy fight for either
candidate Kizer who is one of the OG
Admirals and his devil fruit is just
insanely powerful plus he's basically
guaranteed to show off some really
insane hockey abilities as well that
have never been shown before come on but
again Luffy now has awakened his devil
fruit plus learned advanced form of all
three types of hockey and honestly after
defeating kaido I do think that Luffy's
should theoretically at least be able to
defeat Kiza with as well personally I've
always power scaled the yonko a little
bit higher than the Admiral so since
Luffy defeated kaido then theoretically
that should make him stronger than
kizaru and if that of course were to
happen it would certainly be a huge blow
to the world government overall as it
would be the very first time that an
admiral was actually defeated by a
pirate in the story and yeah I'm not
including the fight with greenball where
he ran away from Shanks at the anovano
which never really got finished and was
just kind of being a coward I guess so
this outcome would make Luffy's
reputation Skyrocket even more and
significantly weaken the overall threats
of the Marines however as we all know
fights in one piece are heavily
dependent on matchups as well so just
because one character should be stronger
than the other doesn't really mean that
they will actually win though honestly
kilaru's fighting style and devil fruit
abilities don't really seem like the
type that would give Luffy a super hard
time I mean it's nothing super crazy or
tricky or confusing for example like the
slow beams that nearly caused Luffy to
lose in Long ring Long Islands because
essentially kizaru fights with shooting
really strong light beams making a light
sword or attacking with light speed
kicks and punches as far as we know at
least and so all of these are
extraordinarily powerful yeah but pretty
straightforward attacks in some way and
so especially with Luffy's Awakening I'm
just wondering if he'll just be able to
grab the light attacks and throw them
back similar to how he was able to catch
the lightning during wano plus since he
can now actually make his environment
rubber as well he should be able to
bounce any light beams back pretty
easily in theory so all this would mean
that Luffy could be defeating kizaru by
the end of this Arc either he dies not
by Luffy of course or the strides could
even capture an admiral who knows but
and yeah that was gonna be a butt to
this I do personally actually think that
the most likely outcome here will be
some sort of draw after all it is
classic Odessa style to show us a clash
of two insanely powerful characters and
then something happens to disrupt the
fight to kind of push it to a later
point in the story and so since Luffy's
main goal at the moment is to escape
with his crew and new friends I could
easily see the fight with kizaru ending
quite early and then the straw hats
managed to escape off the island plus I
don't really think that kizaru has the
type of personality to just go and hunt
them down himself as long as he can
complete his mission of retrieving the
vegapunk tech which we'll talk about
more in just a minute but of course if
we're considering a Luffy win and a draw
then we must also seriously think about
what might happen if kizaru actually
wins this fight because we've actually
never seen kizaru go all out in the
story before so he may very well have
been holding back all this time and so
maybe he actually overwhelms Luffy with
his speed and power hidden hockey other
abilities we don't know about and if
this were to happen it would be
devastating for Luffy and the crew of
course they might not be able to Escape
or at least if Luffy's taken out and
kizaru might just go crazy attacking the
rest of the crew and my God that could
lead to a seriously bad situation for
the straw hats and their friends I could
actually even see someone dying in the
scenario if Luffy isn't there to protect
them possibly a Vega Punk or who knows
even one of the straw hats and and if
that were to happen it would of course
have to mean that Luffy needs way more
power-ups in the future since he will
eventually have to fight with the
Admirals on a level and take down the
world governments and now you might be
thinking that these three are all the
options that we have but there is
actually one more possibility to this
fight that we actually haven't discussed
yet which is that with all of the crazy
technology here on eckon island someone
besides Luffy may actually end up
fighting against kizaru with Luffy or
instead of Luffy because in case you've
forgotten we were actually shown twice
the perfect weapons to fight against the
light fruit user at the start of this
Arc one where this version of vegapunk
here showed off the awesome gloves that
let anyone physically attack light by
punching a hologram and I mean what
better way for someone without hockey to
actually fight against a light devil
fruit user and that's not all because
secondly Bonnie also found that this
ridiculous actual lightsaber that I
would just love to see actually used in
a fight against the Admiral so could we
actually see some of the other straws or
someone else fight alongside or instead
of Luffy against kizaru or maybe even
the different versions of vegapunk
sacrificing themselves to let the rest
of the straw hats Escape I mean it's
certainly possible but if this is the
case then what other incredible event
could shock the entire world then oh
there are quite a few options because we
have to remember that the world
government's main goal here in the first
place is that they came to kill vegapunk
but we also recently learned that
they're now also after the mother flame
technology which is something that helps
them feel the super weapon that
destroyed this entire Island here but at
the same time that wouldn't exactly
seemed like something that would make
World shattering news on its own because
if vegapunk was killed or the government
got their hands on the super powerful
weapon I'm pretty sure that they would
manage to cover it up and the world
doesn't even know about the mother flame
in the first place and so if it's
neither of those then I really only see
two other options here and wow both of
them would seriously change everything
for the one piece world number one can
you imagine the reaction if the gorosei
members sent to ekit islands and Saturn
here was actually killed or captured
during this battle it would be simply
unimaginable and likely cause chaos
throughout the entire world government I
mean we do know that he has some sort of
insane powers from the flashback
Chapters at the reverie but we don't
really know at all how strong he truly
is so if he gets into a fight things
could go very badly or the other option
involves another group of pirates who
have been mysteriously missing from
these last couple of chapters and that's
because you might have forgotten but we
actually got a glimpse of a Blackbeard
ship heading towards echid Island and
assassinating a Top member of the
godosei and then blaming it on the straw
hats seems exactly like the kind of
thing that they would do to cause chaos
throughout the world and I would
definitely see this happening whether
Blackbeard himself is here or it's just
other people from his crew sneaking in
and speaking of that crew there is also
the possibility that Katarina the one
who actually has eaten a shape-shifting
style devil fruit could currently be
posing as an imposter on the island
right now but whether their goal is to
kill the godosei steal Luffy's Pony
glyph copies or something else like
capturing Robin we will have to wait to
actually find out but the other world
shaking event that could happen is that
all of the super secret historical
research that vegapunk has collected
could be shared with the world okay hear
me out I mean we do know that punk
records is basically something like the
internet so what if something happened
and I don't know vegapunk pushed a
magical red button that subscribed him
to this channel for moving and of course
it would mostly send all of that super
secret data to the entire world this
would literally be the world
government's worst nightmare right now
because vegapunk has information about
the void century and the ancient
kingdoms and secret Tech that he
developed for the government itself and
so if that's not enough to shake up the
entire world then I really don't know
what would be however while all of this
is speculation we do know that Lucci is
right now actively trying to kill
vegapunk once again and Zorro has
stepped up to stop him which honestly is
a little bit disappointing for both
characters I mean Lucci God watched by
Luffy so now he has to fight the second
in command and I personally feel like
Zorro should handle Luchi no problem at
all since he has unlocked his Advanced
contrast hockey too on the other hand
Lucci is an awakened Zone fruit user now
so we'll have to see how much of an
actual fight Oda decides to make this
but really the the fight that I and I
think most of you also would have loved
to see instead would have been Zorro
against kizaru that surely would have
been way more of a challenge than Lucci
and would have pushed Zorro literally to
his ultimate limits and even though I
desperately want to see this fight I
actually don't think that Zorro would
win at the moment at least which also
makes me wonder how Zoro is going to
grow stronger in the future here on outs
and so maybe to help him fight the top
tiers of the story he might in the end
need a completely different power up
such as an ultra powerful devil fruit
and if you want to see just how insane
the story would get if Zoro actually ate
a devil fruit you can watch that video
right here thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one